you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
it goes without saying that the personal
computer revolutionized businesses and
homes around the globe but what was the
very first one where did it come from
and what's the story behind it
interestingly enough as you'll find out
in this video the PC was the impetus for
both Microsoft and Apple let's begin we
have to travel back in time here to
where this story has its prelude the mid
20th century at this time the computer
was a big deal
you usually needed clearance to see one
let alone use one this made it almost
impossible for any inquisitive minds to
use one without time sharing at this
time in film and television computers
were seen as large all-knowing devices
often referred to as the mechanical
brain try and replace it all with a
mechanical brain he's under special
assignment to ally to see if Emmerich
can be adapted to this department that
means the end of his own hey calm down
no machine can do our job that's what
they said in a roll think about it from
a person of the 1950s and 60s point of
view all your life you'd been using
manual tools such as slide rules or
charts to do calculations and then came
an automatic computer which could
magically do the math for you but then
after this something amazing happened
computer technology began to evolve in
capabilities and it started doing logic
and was programmed to even play chess
things that traditionally required
intelligence in 1952 a computer called
univac predicted the outcome of the u.s.
presidential election by using some
clever code and inputs on the results of
previous races
univac is going to try to predict the
winner for us just as early as we can
possibly get the returns then this is
not a joke or a
it's an experiment we think it's going
to work we don't know we hope it'll work
the machine turned out this answer that
they didn't believe the poles were
telling him that was going to be about a
50/50 election and we were telling him
it's a landslide with only 5% of the
vote and they couldn't believe that you
could predict the thing as accurately as
we did which was when a few percent with
only 5% of the vote so everybody was
thrown into total confusion for the
Republic it was me people were shocked
and symbolically from that moment the
computer had truly arrived in the minds
of the people it could do anything
here's a 1960s East German film
depicting a future computer of 1987
films such as this captured the
imagination of anyone watching in the
day globally young tech minds would have
been entranced by the concept of a
computer growing up one of those young
minds was Bill Gates an in January of
1975 he saw a magazine cover that would
change his life and the course of
history that magazine was popular
electronics and on the cover of that
magazine was a personal computer in an
instant all the possibilities were now
within reach there'll be more on Bill
Gates later but first where did this
computer come from well one year earlier
in 1974 Edie Roberts an engineer was
trying to prevent his calculator
business from going under at a meeting
with his bank lenders in a last-ditch
attempt to save the company he said that
he could do something that hadn't been
done before create a personal computer
kit for hobbyists a task thought to be
impossible at the time and only made
possible by the microprocessor invented
by Intel just three years earlier in
1971 for a bit of context the
microprocessor for the first time
allowed an entire computer to be put
onto one chip a truly huge feat Roberts
name the microprocessor driven computer
the Altair 8800 and soldered in the
pages of the popular electronics
magazine for $400 in January of 1975
Edie Roberts told the bank that they
expected a few hundred orders of the
most so ended up being swamped with a
couple of thousand orders within the
first few months at that time all the
computers in the world tended to be in
big centers and you had to get
permission to get close to them and it
was you know you said nobody could
nobody had access to computers and the
idea that you could have your own
computer do whatever you wanted to with
it whenever you wanted to was fantastic
the demand for the computer was so high
that enthusiastic hobbyists parked
outside of the front of his warehouse to
get their hands on the computers the
enthusiasm was driven by the fact that
now everything that these guys had
dreamed of and seen in movies was now
within reach of everyone and moreover it
could fit on your desk
well almost you see the Altair 8800 was
a very primitive there was no place to
connect a keyboard or monitor it was
just a bunch of switches and lights
although very simple the Altair 8800
started a revolution in mid 1975 a club
was started in California in which
enthusiasts gathered to discuss
everything about the Altair 8800 the
club's name was the homebrew Computer
Club and one of the enthusiasts was a
guy named Steve Wozniak Wozniak later
stated that it would be the very first
meeting at the homebrew Computer Club
that inspired him to build his own
computer which he would bring to each
weekly meeting this computer eventually
became the Apple one the computer that
started Apple in addition to being
primitive the Altair 8800 was very
difficult to use to load an instruction
he had to flip switches for example
let's look at how you'd load two plus
two
each two took 8 different switches and a
knife switch to load them all the Plus
instruction took 8 more switches and you
would know that the answer was 4 when
the third light from the left turned on
a 100 byte program would take 100
switches it kind of makes me thankful
for the ease of use of computers today
despite the hurdles though the guys at
the computer Club was smart enough to
come up with uses for it
Steve Dampier set up an altar laborious
leaky to program him to it somebody
knocked a plug out of the wall and he
had to do that all over again but nobody
knew what this was about after all and
wasn't just going to sit and flash his
lights no you put a little up transistor
radio next to the L tear and he would
bike manipulating the length of loops in
the software could play tunes the radio
began playing the fool on the hill and
the tinny little tunes that you could
tell we're coming from the noise that
the computer was generated being picked
up by the radio everybody rose and
applauded it was a very exciting thing
it was probably the first thing the LT
air actually did although this
demonstration blew minds at the time in
order to be a useful tool the machine
needed a programming language as it
turns out Paul Allen a high school
friend of Bill Gates saw the magazine
cover with the 8800 proudly sitting on
it he snatched it off the shelf and ran
into bills college dorm room when Bill
saw it he knew that this was it the
personal computer had arrived but
instead of getting excited bill saw a
business opportunity and called up ed
Roberts his company met and told them
that he'd written some software for the
8800 and it was almost completed the
thing was they hadn't even started
writing it yet and saw this popular
electronics magazine and it was kind of
in a way you know good news bad news
here was someone making a computer
around this chip in exactly the way that
Paul had talked to me in
thought about what kind of software
could be done for it and it was
happening without us and for all we knew
maybe they had some software people they
were just going to go charge off and do
this thing because we never had the chip
just the book from Intel if we'd made
any mistake in terms of how the
instructions worked it never I think
never would have run and so Paul was
scheduled to fly out to Albuquerque he
decided to go get some sleep
I stayed up all night reading the book
to see if we miscoded some of the
instructions and finally decided it was
all okay punch out the paper tape and
made sure Paul got that before he went
off on his plane he wrote the bootstrap
loader that is the thing you have to key
in to make this computer smart enough to
know to go get data off the teletype to
read it into memory he wrote that on the
plane on the way out loaded up in the
paper tape the first time for some
reason it didn't work the second time
they loaded in and it worked so it came
up said ready and he typed in a program
you know print 2+2 it worked he had to
print out squares and sums and and
things like that and he and and Roberts
the end of his company sat there and
they were amazed by you know that this
thing worked I mean Paul was amazed that
that our part had worked and in ed was
amazed his hardware worked and this was
the first piece of Microsoft software
after this moment the 19 year old Bill
Gates saw that he could get an early
foothold on the new PC industry and
immediately quit University and went to
live in New Mexico out of a hotel
directly across the road from the mitts
factory the company that made the Altair
machine from this hotel bill and Paul
got to work writing more software for
the 8800 their software allowed the 8800
to now do much more by the end of the
year people had attached terminals to
the out air and wrote games accounting
software and word processors on top of
Bill and Allen software code now called
Microsoft the true revolution had begun
the simple computer with switches and
lights had now become a functioning
machine closer to what we call a PC
today just in the span of one
yeah and this was all thanks to the
software that these two kids wrote and
as we know the rest went pretty well for
Microsoft so there you have it the
Altair 8800 the little-known first
personal computer if it didn't exist
there would be no Microsoft or Apple as
we know them today or perhaps even at
all and as a side point I think it's
really cool that we can now just click a
mouse and tap on a screen to load some
software instead of flipping hundreds of
switches we should be grateful for that
anyway thanks for watching if you think
more people should learn about this
golden piece of history feel free to
share this video also give it a thumbs
up if you liked it or thumbs down if you
didn't if you want to see some more cool
stuff from this channel hang around for
the next 10 seconds and follow the
prompts in your screen this has been -
gogo
you've been watching ColdFusion cheers
guys and I'll catch you again soon for
the next video have a good one
ColdFusion
it's rethinking